[Music]
we've got a great new role being
advertised at waimate district council
we're gonna catch up with the boss Simon
and find out more yeah so we've got a
new business and centers advisor role
being advertised right at the moment the
role is pretty exciting
it focuses on two main things the first
is helping new businesses and growing
businesses in our district navigate our
regulatory services and the other part
of the role is really to help us review
the Town Center plan documents that we
have in the framework that we have
around town centre planning and then
implement a whole series of projects
that come out of that planning framework
all right sounds really interesting so
what sort of person are you looking for
Hey look the person's got to be quite
excited about working in local
government and helping with economic
development they've got to be really
excited about building good
relationships with local business
community and look they've got to have
an element of innovation and Flair to
come up with really great solutions best
practice solutions for both our business
partners in the council
[Music]